abgemagerte kühe die zentimeter tief in
ihren eigenen fäkalien stehen und liegen
manche haben massive entzündungen und
krankheiten an den klauen
diese bilder aus einem milchvieh hof im
oberallgäuer dietmannsried stammen von
einem tierrechtsaktivisten wir haben
hier tiere gesehen die nur noch auf zwei
beinen sich hüpfend fortbewegen konnten
und auch einen sehr schlechten
ernährungszustand gezeigt haben es ist
nicht der erste tierschutz skandal im
allgäu in diesem groß viel betrieb in
bad grönenbach im unterallgäu mit 1800
rindern haben tierschützer letzten
sommer diese bilder aufgenommen
kühe und kälber werden aufgehängt
getreten geschlagen in die flanken
gestochen und wie gegenstände von einem
ort zum anderen geschleift kranke tiere
verenden abgemagert und teils mit
offenen wunden über tage hinweg im stall
als reaktion auf diesen skandal führte
bayerns umwelt- und verbraucherminister
thorsten glauber vor einem halben jahr
ein neues kontrollsystem 1
vor allem großbetriebe werden seitdem
intensive und unangekündigt kontrolliert
dafür werden jetzt neue stellen für
veterinäre geschaffen
auch der hof in dietmannsried mit 600
rindern wurde in den letzten anderthalb
jahren mehrfach kontrolliert
dabei wurden immer wieder verstöße gegen
das tierwohl festgestellt es gab
mahnungen und anordnungen
doch der landwirt konnte seinen betrieb
trotz der missstände ungehindert weiter
führen
diese verstöße wurden auch entsprechend
weitergemeldet hin zitiert dessen dass
ein landwirt sogenannte direktzahlungen
erhält aufgrund dessen dass diese
verstöße auch aktenkundig waren sind die
direktzahlungen gekürzt wurden
kontrollen allein reichen nicht aus so
die opposition in bayern
der neue skandal zeige für das tierwohl
müsse bei solchen mißständen schneller
und härter durchgegriffen werden
ich glaube wir haben ein grundsätzliches
problem auf jeden fall in bayern
vielleicht auch in ganz deutschland dass
die behörden bei tierschutz verstoßen
einfach nicht durchgreifen immer nur
anordnungen zu erlassen und dann zu
sagen ja der tierhalter hat nicht darauf
reagiert es reicht überhaupt nicht aus
da müssen aus meiner sicht andere saiten
aufgezogen werden ansonsten ist es
einfach schlicht staatsversagen auf dem
hof in dietmannsried waren manche tiere
in einem so miserablen zustand
dass sie eingeschläfert werden mussten
das oberallgäuer landratsamt will den
betrieb nun die tierhaltung verbieten